get the changes before the show or I
know the drill you just point the camera
my direction we'll figure it out
together always sound so simple and yet
so moronic George and Julia are used to
figuring it out together money master is
their fourth film mark I think it's a
story about all of us feeling in control
or not in control of our own lives
jordans leave a TV financial host taken
hostage julia is his producer anyone who
can get out get out right now she is
trying to stay calm and collected and
connected to lead to keep him calm and
to understand what's going on in the
studio at the same time trying to find
the people and trying to find what's
really going on George's kidnapper it's
a guy who lost it all in the market why
a sinister global conspiracy that julia
has got to quickly uncover just keep
talking to him all right you're good at
that we love the idea of talking about
the world of money and how it's gotten
out of control when those things all go
wrong did the little guy kind of get
screwing I thought those are really
interesting things oscar-winner Jodie
Foster directs the movie and she says
Clooney is uniquely qualified for this
role as a TV personality you know he's a
movie star who quietly is unafraid to
you know look at the at the darker sides
of himself you know at the smaller size
of his own minute that Jodi asked if I
wanted to play the part I thought whoosh
I'll be perfectly safe working with Jody
because she she'll take care of actors I
don't want you to die oh my god no no
those together good evident and we're
hearing that George Julia and Jody will
all be at a camp film festival for the
premiere of money master and get this
that's actually gonna be Julia's first
time to can